in news that should surprise no one news  rudy giuliani is apparently having a  hard time getting president trump to pay  for his legal services rudy giuliani  made headlines earlier this year by  apparently seeking up to 20 thousand  dollars per day to represent the  president of course president trump has  a history of stiffing his  creditors now the interesting thing here  is that lawyers aren't really allowed to  just  stop representing a client if they're in  active litigation the court will often  see if it's a good time if it would  prejudice the client for the  attorney to just leave in the middle of  proceedings but then again a lawyer  doesn't have to take on additional  representation which might actually  explain why rudy has refused to  represent the president  at his upcoming impeachment trial  lawyers are just the worst  until you need one so stay tuned for  more legal analysis and as always i'll  see you  in court